how's it going brother bad as you may or
may not have seen I got to be on South
Park what are you watching I think Oh
Lily any TV show ever could call me up
and be like hey you want to be part of
our show and I would probably turn it
down and that's not because I'm I'm too
cool for that [ __ ] it's just well it's
number one I can't act believe it or not
number two I I don't have an interest in
doing stuff like that I I I feel pretty
comfortable with what I do on YouTube
but anything outside of that is this why
but to be part of South Park that's just
something different and I'm just so
happy about it they reach out to me
about a month ago and asked if I wanted
to be a part of the show and obviously I
said yes but when the time actually came
it was right before I was going to Japan
I'm always crazy busy before I go to
trips and they needed me to do the lines
while I was in Japan so I had to bring
my setup to Japan and it looked pretty
ridiculous I have a photo we say that a
ryokan which is a traditional Japanese
in so for me to yell and do the lines
there is probably the worst place ever
and they got really upset that I was
being too loud and to top it all off I
got the flu while I was in Japan so I
was so sick when I did the line so he
didn't it came out really bad on my end
but hey I got to be on South Park so
it's okay looking back from when I
started in Sweden four years ago to now
and and where we are now is just unreal
to me and I didn't want to make this
video to just show off and be like yeah
I got to be on South Park [ __ ] I'm so
[ __ ] cold cuz no one would believe
that but because
putting in perspective YouTube has done
a lot for me and day and I realized that
none of it would happen if it wasn't
thanks to you Bruce you stick with me
throughout the whole way and and I have
I have so much to thank for that's how I
feel like and I hope more new cool
possibilities will open up in the future
and I hope to keep making videos the way
I've been doing and I hope you bros to
keep enjoying them like you've been
doing I hope but really necessarily
thank you Bruce for always being there I
really really do appreciate it so happy
where I am right now and so happy all
these things are happening and I just
feel very Christmassy and oh kattiline
shed so here's to many more days of the
bros and i'll see you in the next video
as always stay awesome Roche